Three days! I made it. None of you thought I would get this far, did you?
Hi guys, my name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know, now you know. Your life is different now.
It's Friday here on It'sGrace and it's time to comment on your motherf*ckin'
comments, you filthy, nasty perverts. Let's do it, let's turn over on twitter.
It's that platform, where I constantly feel socially responsible for posting
jokes, and I don't because
my brain is mashed potatoes, so i post a lot of gifs of people and babies falling down. Samifeenan! New person, new person, new person.
Also this happens in these videos. If you don't know, when a new person comments on my
social media platforms, I grace the crap out of them and welcome them to the It'sGrace family.
How do I know if it's new person? I don't know, I just guess, aka, every single f*cking person is new. It's nice to be new?
Unless you're in high school or joining an AA.
Samifeenan, more like, Sammy pee man, just prove you can
pee so I could stop thinking that you're an AI robot. This isn't perverted.
It's just- I'm trying to save my life, cause, AI is gonna kill us all. You, seem otherwise, like a great person or-
a murder robot. You've been Graced! "Hey Grace Helbig, any chance you're bringing back the I don't know hoodies? I'm a dumb dumb and missed out the first time."
You are an idiot. Just kidding. Technically they're, not coming back, however if you guys-
any of you that didn't get one this time around- are interested, leave a comment down below. And let me know
because, we might be able in the future. Flashback Friday campaign, I don't know.
*burps*
A burp is just a flashback Friday to the food you ate earlier.
I either just blew my own mind or I fell asleep with my eyes open, because I'm so bored with myself. Who knows?
KitaCotter! New person, new person, new person. KitaCotter, more like-
keep your cooter. Get it, keep it. You've been Graced. "It's day two of Grace Helbig posting everyday in November, I'm super-"
"proud, she's keeping up with it. Also surprised, but I believe she can do it. Guys, it's day two. It's eye opening, how-
many of you are so proud of me for posting two videos, and also how
many of you are surprised that I have posted only two videos, consecutively, it's an educational experience on how
inconsistent I had been being. So...
Thank you for holding up a really supportive mirror to my sloppy floppy
inconsistent ways. Snayl! New person, new person, new person. Snayl, more like-
*awkward silence*
Did i just do an impression of a snake,? Uh-oh, the snails have gotten into my brain. You've been Graced. "Didn't know Grace Helbig knew
House Ways and Means Committee Chairman Kevin Brady. Weird!"
Okay, first of all, the bored listening face, if that ain't me. But that woman-
that ain't me.
But I truly do relate to her natural resting hate, bored face. Now let's go to Instagram!
I'm bad at that. Caitlin Kantor! New person, new person, new person. Caitlin Kantor, more like Caitlin can-
tornadoes take your virginity? Asking for a friend.
You've been Graced. "When all the girls in kindergarten dressed as Disney princesses, I went as a box of popcorn.
My costume was a cardboard box with popped popcorn on it. The boys in my class kept eating
my costume." I don't want to go there, but did you just say that the boys
in your class couldn't stop eating your, box? I went there, I would like to now leave there, and return to here.
We're back. Oddrey Ellis! New person, new person, new person. Oddrey Ellis, more like-
Aah, relish...
Doesn't taste good. You've been Graced. "I just came from your channel
and I'm commenting on this, because I seek attention and validation." If that ain't me. Also side brainstorm
a perfume called attention-seeking, I'd buy it immediately. You can't have that idea, I need the validation.
Tristanreid74! New person, new person, new person. Tristanreid74, more like Tristan-
read 74 books and tell me, what it's like to be a person that-
genuinely enjoys reading books. You've been Graced!
"Lol,I think the real question is who was taking a picture
instead of helping?" This is a photo of Hannah Hart and I, years ago, outside of jumbo's clown room.
Which is a place that dancers in scantily clad outfits dance. It's not a strip club,
they don't get naked, but they dance provocatively and people throw money at them. It's like a fun strip
club. It's not as sad. And we tied one on that night and then Hannah decided to help me to the car...
Gravity and sobriety were not on either of our sides, nor was good decision-making.
So... Honestly the friend that took this photo was indeed helping the situation, because I
didn't have an Instagram photo to post that night. Now let's go to YouTube! It- it's all so-and-so...
And...
Slateflash! New person, new person, new person. Slateflash, more like-
What you call the side effects of
Marvel going through menopause slight flashes. You've been Graced! "The only time chlamydia sounds hot is when Grace says it. This is a
weird compliment, Grace, take it or leave it." I'm gonna take the compliment, I'mma leave the chlamydia. The Grace Helbig story.
Marie Creasbaum! New person, new person, new person. Marie Creasbaum, more like, Marie request some-
Bomb-ass stank-ass ass. You deserve a great partnership with someone that loves you as much as you love that that bomb-ass stank-
ass ass. You've been Graced! "I so badly wanted this to be a sexy mail costumes." I'm sorry that I didn't deliver.
Ow! That one hurt me as much as it hurt you.
SurviveYourDay! New person, new person, new person. SurviveYourDay, more like, don't tell me how to live my life. Also thank you for the encouragement.
Also, also one more time, for those in the back: You've been Graced. "For fuck's sake,
Grace, it's Joann Fabrics. Singular. SINGULAR." I know that now because a lot of you pointed it out. In my brain it
was Joann's Fabrics, because a woman named Joann decided to venture out on a...
Business plan to open up a craft store. Instead of Joann Fabrics, which is just maybe a woman named Joann Fabrics that
also coincidentally happens to have affinity for crafting and open up business
about it. That's fucked up, but thank you for the correction. The internet's here to correct and condemn. Sebastian!
New person, new person, new person. Sebastian, more like, how tha-
how do you get your fish fins to type on the computer screen. Sebastian? Little mermaid?
*awkard silence*
You've been Graced. "I haven't watched it yet, does Grace get killed, by an axe murderer?  I hope not." Me too! Okay.
That's it for commenting on your comments, you guy. Make sure that you follow me on all social media platforms and leave
some comments so I might comment on them in the future. Don't forget to subscribe to this YouTube channel.
I'm making videos all through the month of Gracevember, and give this video a thumbs up if you
like commenting on comments videos. Other than that...
Th- I don't know.
Gracie-
777101! New person, new person, new person. Gracie777101, more like, quick brand building lesson:
No numbers in your screen name. You've been Graced. "You should, make DIY snow." Isn't that just ice? Or freezer burn? How
do I do this? I'm curious, but I think this might also be stupid. If you guys
want me to make DIY snow, let me know. Let me snow.
No...
Gross. I hate myself.
Menopause, I couldn't remember the word menopause.
It's what I was looking for. Because I couldn't remember it, I googled what's it called 'when women go through adult puberty'?
*laughs*
Menopause! Alright.